so I have members of my family who have
obviously experienced the shake that
they've been outside they've been
sleeping outside it's it's scary because
it's people who are very close to me you
know I've had numerous people um on
Instagram reach out to me they've sent
me locations of an address pictures live
and it's like they are screaming for
help and I want to use my platform as
much as I can to help you know anyone
out there from Syria and turkey as soon
as the opportunity was given to me I'm
there
um obviously it's my home it's my second
language and anything I can do I'm there
to support anyone so first opportunity
I'll be there